To start off, I went ahead and
created all the variables that I knew I would need.
I needed family1, family2, bruce, madison, and hunter.
For family2, bruce, madison and hunter, I went ahead and
passed in a string of an HTML element to the jQuery object.
This creates a new DOM element.
I made sure to include these h1, h2 and h3 tags so
I would know what I was looking at when I saw the page.
After that, it was a simple matter of inserting family2 after family1,
appending bruce to family2, and then madison and hunter to bruce.
But I want you to take a look at the syntax of .insertAfter because it's
a little different than what we've seen before with jQuery.
insertAfter acts on some DOM element and then inserts it after the target.
I also want you to notice that we could have used this command called
.after instead.
.after follows more normal jQuery syntax.
It acts on a selector and then adds some content after it.
We can go ahead and
check our work by looking at the resulting page, which looks pretty good.
And we can open up DevTools to make sure that the DOM is
the way that we'd expect it to look